as we continue to learn more about this
murder more questions about the crime
itself are emerging our heather mills
sat down with retired district attorney
david roger to learn more about how
police are conducting this investigation
let me ask you this because the sheriff
mentioned that there might be some
grainy video which may show the actual
violent crime and this is a violent
crime
but they're saying you know with dna
evidence with this straw hat that they
found in the house with a bloody shoe
they don't have the murder weapon do
they need that to make this case
ironclad
no they don't know him or they don't
need the murder weapon they know how
jeff gearman was killed the medical
examiner will be able to say that he was
stabbed
to death
all they need to do is link tell us to
the crime and with the fact that you
know they have
you know
video of someone who matches his
description who has a similar gait as
him the fact that
that person is seen driving away in a
vehicle that it appears to be similar to
his vehicle the fact that they have him
washing his vehicle
right after
the the press conference in which they
announced that that was a person and a
vehicle that they were looking for you
know they have
it's been reported i don't know
that they have
mr german's dna connected to to telus
you know at the time of an autopsy they
will take fingernail scrapings
to determine whether there's dna under
the fingernails and you know if they
have mr talus's dna
under jeff german's fingernails that's
pretty good evan so they don't need a
murder weapon it'd be nice to have it
but it's not necessary